big article on Donald Trump and had all
these strange was in the New York Times
it was like I was like minutiae minutiae
weird things about his life and in this
new article on President trumpet says he
views each workday like an episode of a
TV show yes like a TV show in a way
Trump's right because with his low
ratings people are wondering why he
hasn't been canceled yet over the
weekend President Trump was in
Mississippi speaking at the Civil Rights
Museum and he called civil rights this
is a quote big big stuff yeah now to be
fair Trump was just paraphrasing dr.
King's famous speech I have a thing
[Laughter]
Sunday big election tomorrow in Alabama
hope you're all going to vote
oh if only they could if only you could
all just go pull a lever and then run
away
yeah I'm from Alabama yeah and how in
tomorrow's election Alabama has to
choose between two things they find
abhorrent that's right a pedophile and a
Democrat it's kind of
no no no no you just wanted to see if I
could get a laugh creating the obvious
saying yeah and also saying the word
pedophile for difficulty of the dive for
a joke that is near impossible a right
and I didn't make it did you hear this
last week a YouTube prankster had his
friends cement his head into a microwave
oven to make a mold of his features yeah
unfortunately he's going to be okay
[Applause]
you